literally our first kiss was so awful
like that's what you said oh no
it was like kissing a brick wall like
there was nothing going on
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax podcast
with your favorite favorite sisters i
didn't really hear the energy in your
voice can you chew it one more time for
me this is probably the second episode
in a row that you've made me restart but
i just want to make sure season two is
starting off strong you're giving me
about five percent you can do it then
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwaxed podcast
with your favorite sisters sophia and
sistine
you know
trial and error baby it's okay
maybe we need to switch off once in a
while because my my voice seems a little
are you okay today yeah i don't think i
had enough coffee really yeah honestly i
usually drink two cups it was just one
and i thought you know or full addicted
we're fully addicted i don't get
migraines but now i get migraines if i
don't drink coffee yeah and i've been
reading a lot of studies saying that i
should probably weigh off coffee for a
bit and i don't know if i physically
can't i really my whole body now runs
and works if you know what i mean
because of coffee like i cannot
function at all without it and i don't
know how i'm going to be able to do that
well we both know how we feel about tea
drinkers so that's just not enough the
worst you wanna hear something funny
that mom did this morning yeah so i
didn't realize that i think she was
teaching us when we were young or
something to like how to do this so that
she can use this language at this moment
if this makes sense let me explain
elaborate so basically i'm sitting um at
the kitchen with mom and dad's there and
i think she wanted to tell me something
without
dad hearing so all of a sudden she
starts speaking piglet and i swear to
god
i didn't even hesitate and i responded
back what and she's never done that to
us since we were how like 12. so she was
speaking pig latin to keep secrets from
sly in front of sly yeah and he like
kind of looked at her like what is she
saying and he just went back to the
thing but i knew exactly what she was
saying what was she saying
i can't say it say it in pig latin
people won't understand because remember
mommy's always come up to this
like middle school
isn't that like that was the thing like
we all did it and then my my mom i'm
gonna piggyback off of the middle school
comment because we were just talking
about this off camera
the chat rooms that we used to be a part
of in middle school do you remember them
you had a different one than i had yeah
we had form spring does anyone remember
form spring form spring is you have an
account and everyone does and you can
ask people anonymous questions and it
got
ugly wait it can get so bad
mine didn't get ugly
ask fm
you're i feel like yours is more rogue
than when i no i love to ask fm because
the whole grade would say cameron who do
you have a crush on and then
someone would comment like delilah and
sophie and everyone's names got uh
mentioned and everyone got a crush
everyone had wait you're the bigger but
ours was not innocent but i always got
in my feels because no one ever put me
in their answers no but ever
sistine do you remember it i don't know
if this was just an la thing but we had
something called bathroom wall
do you ever remember that
okay i guarantee some people are
probably like no and triggered because
basically what it is is it's a site that
you get to write anonymously anything
about anybody and it was kind of
happening in the la district and so
people would write like they're the hot
like the hottest five girls the ones the
best ass like the hottest guys and like
who's not a good kisser and it just got
kind of a genuine massively bad like i'm
so i never was mentioned and honestly i
checked all the time to see you yeah i
was saying i checked all the time like
did someone say i had anything i wanted
something something i was gonna crash i
never had like best boobs i got nothing
no mine was like best study guides
that was like best braces
best legs no it was literally like i
never got mentioned in anything and then
someone actually reminded me in college
and i don't know if this was just
happening for one year because it had a
very short-lived run it was uh yik yak
wait you were still doing this in
college
and checking these chat rooms oh i
always did i always did oh you shouldn't
see if i was cool and now he wasn't cool
enough to ever be mentioned well
whatever look at us now look at us now
but we also mentioned i don't know if
anyone remembers that really sketchy
game i am vu
do you remember that i don't know if
we've talked about this on the podcast
but
if this game is still up and run running
it needs to be shut down get off it it's
so creepy it's just a way for old men to
pry on young girls and let me tell you
it happened to us yeah we tried it
because we said oh cool it was like kind
of the first anime intro we got and
that's just the girls but then we didn't
even question the fact that you they
could be like fully nude how old were we
i think we're like 12. we really see
this is the funny thing i think seeing
this
anime
uh
what would you call this sort of
character like um like a
what are you talking about like a
whatever it is i think sort of seeing
this anime naked well playing a video
game was the first time i've seen like
someone naked
and i was like am i being introduced the
wrong way okay probably someone gets
introduced yeah i have such unrealistic
expectations of normal bodies now
because i'm just expecting them just
virtual pixelated pixelated
and just completely unrealistic yeah but
we would talk to these strange men i
know thinking that they were also 12
year old boys i know we thought it was
the coolest thing ever i don't know if
it's still out but i remember we would
go back to bed everything panicked well
we spent a lot of time on the internet
growing up
yeah we did a lot of time and that's
kind of why i'm really excited to
have the guest on that we do today
because that is exactly what this girl
is it's funny enough i met her
um at an event in new york fashion week
when i was just there and
she first of all is so stunning
so stunning and just the nicest person
and then when i found out what she does
i was like okay she's a badass gorgeous
gamer girl can you get a better
combination she is literally what we
wish we could be wait that's i think i
would consider myself do not call
yourself a gamer i am a gamer
i play cod i play assassin's creed iv i
play online chess and black is that
count what i play online chess does that
count you do not play online chess ever
i've never seen you what i do online
chat in my words the only person that
plays any online games is mom and she
does an obsessive amount of solitude i
play red beard remember that game i
still play red beard what's red beard i
played webkinz
okay i love penguins club penguin oh so
i am a gamer in theory okay i did i'm on
football that's kind of game are we
competing right guys guess what i'm
first place still you are i am i'm
winning i'm first playing how many guys
are you beating right now 12.
you're being 12 and this is my first
year and i've never played before and i
went rogue and i chose everything
opposite from the whole world you're
literally beating 12 x football players
yeah literally based off of the fact
that you chose your players because i
thought they were the hottest right
thank you actually that's not fair
because i do watch all or nothing i do
get into it i don't know any stats
though watch this one tv show i know
football i'm like i watch heart knocks
see no but i'm excited to have this girl
brook on because
there's something so cool and sexy about
being a female
and being a gamer
you're putting the two worlds together
yeah really hello hello oh god i wanted
to teach me something yeah i mean we i
don't know anything about the gaming
world the people in it maybe it's
different from what we're used to
because we're more in entertainment
world how are the gaming i know i'm
curious to see because you know
internet's again scary place let's see
what she deals with maybe not on imvu
like us but definitely something a
little bit cooler oh my god i really
hope she did play that we can ask her
okay okay stay tuned
[Music]
this beauty or more commonly known as
brook a b on social media is a twitch
streamer gamer and content creator she
has blown up real quick with almost a
million instagram followers 1.2 million
followers on twitch and a partnership
with a hundred thieves and so much more
we're already clicking right off the bat
with this girl this is brooke
hello hello okay look how beautiful she
looks
you come in first of all
your outfit spectacular really i mean i
was in a panic i was ripping apart i'm
like do you have a long stone shirt like
i was freaking out that's us that's well
this morning i could not put anything
together so i was like screw it a crew
like [ __ ] hoodie whatever this is jeans
like i can't do it you guys look amazing
no hair is disgusting but way too much
concealer foundation yeah we're
literally caked up over here but you
look gorgeous yeah oh my god the
struggles but thank you so much for
coming on today
i was just telling the listeners that i
met you in new york yeah i was like this
girl right off the bat you have one of
those energies that just completely
captivate and like bring everyone in
around you like you're so bubbly and
positive
and that's why i think what you do
because you're like a live stream or a
twitch streamer like that's probably why
you have such a great following because
you just like attract people towards you
thank you i'm sure but like
let's get into it because i really want
to know and maybe sort of you can give
the listener some context to like what
it is exactly that you do yeah so
i live stream on twitch which is i i do
like the youtube videos all that stuff
which is like my main thing um so
i pretty much just press go live i have
my little camera in the corner who like
hasn't seen a stream like you can see me
you see the game yeah but then you can
like chat with me while i'm live so yeah
that's kind of like my favorite part of
it is like the chat can talk to me i can
talk back to them things like that so
i i love streaming but like
it's um
like very
very stressful so tell me why yeah
i think that having that many people
like watching you at once it's like
public speaking almost right like you're
literally in front of
thousands of people and you're supposed
to just be like hi i'm gonna totally
express myself i watched her live
yesterday um on twitch and i was like
why are you saying that it was like it
was called valorent or whatever oh yeah
is that a game yes okay
yeah okay and i saw you we were playing
like with your friends you talked and i
was going to ask like how are you able
to literally talk to the camera talk to
the chat room yeah play games also look
good like i was like yeah i was like i
could barely walk into them it's a lot
of like multitasking it really is yeah
because you're like you have to read but
then it'll get you killed in the game
because you're reading it that's what
i'm saying yeah no it's it's very
stressful how long did it take to get
used to that well i started when i
started i started with fortnite so whoa
whoa whoa i love fortnite okay so i've
never played what i feel like i'm the
only human that hasn't played it yet it
was it was big and but like yeah i was
always dead because i wasn't good so it
was like i was able to talk to my child
all the time so that's so i love it i
love it but what i what i was
what i would get nervous about streaming
is that there are no cuts like it's
fully just you can't edit something out
if someone walks in the background or if
you say something stupid or for you look
bad like it's out there oh my god you
can't go back the amount of mental
breakdowns i have literally on the
middle of school oh my gosh that's why i
was like panicking when you're like i
watched yesterday i was like do you have
a panic attack no i like
i mean you're live like sometimes eight
hours a day like your whole day is with
them so i'm like if i'm like having a
bad day i will literally be like to my
channel like be quiet don't talk to me i
was reading even like through the
comments and like people are so weird on
it a little bit i'm like and i can see
like you can like block comments and
make sure like that's which is good i
was like i saw you did that i was like
yeah good girl
i got really invested in it and i was
like i did not think i would get it it's
fun to watch people do it but the
response is really interesting because
like do people what has it been like so
far your experience have you gotten a
lot of creepy guys have you gotten a lot
of supportive people or is it kind of
just a mix of everything it's i mean
it's a huge mix of everything i would
say like the support outweighs all the
weirdos by a lot i think there's so many
weirdos out there it's like it's mostly
men probably yeah oh yeah like it's just
so come on guys male 1 yeah sorry come
on but it's true like i mean just you
get them asking for weird things like
stand up turn around on the camera like
just windows how about this you get on
live you stand up and turn up exactly
first yeah so i mean it definitely it's
a balance and the support is like huge
and everyone's really nice yeah but like
the weirdos stand out because okay so
how did it even start though because i
don't were you ever into gaming
originally or yeah so i grew up i gamed
my whole life my sister and i grew up
we've had xbox like we always played oh
gosh that's oh yeah yeah scarlet nice
girl would watch me play
but you know she's like
but scarlett plays now
that's the difference but go ahead okay
yeah well my sister was the one who was
playing and i would always watch
yourself
yeah so that was me i was like i'm not
gonna play but now i do play right so we
always played growing up and then when
i got to college and fortnite was like
the thing like everyone was freaking out
um i would go over my friends houses and
like that's all they would be doing so i
was like hand it over yeah
yeah so they're like why don't you
stream if you play video games i was
like i don't even know what that is so
right i looked into it and i was like i
can't like i streamers always say
they're like if you're going in to make
money don't do it like which is true but
like i went into it because i was like i
need some bucks to make it through
college
i think they're all lying yeah to be
honest like a lot of work yeah i was
like i mean i'm a broke college student
i'll take an extra twenty dollars if
someone wants to
hand it over
because that's how it works on streaming
people can just send you money yeah so
like my first month streaming i had this
random guy come in and give me like
2 500. i never saw him again just
because so it's like the most random
thing so like people can donate to you
literally i was like wait so why why do
they donate like what is the is there
like
so you can just sign up for twitch go
live and people can yeah just like fund
you almost like right yeah going like
probably yeah so they can subscribe
yeah so subscriptions are five dollars a
month um and that's just like
you can chat if like i'm in sub only
chat or you get like perks and no ads
things like that but you can also just
like straight up donate like
a tip and so some people will like do
a 2500 tip and you'll never see them
again okay that's amazing i'm convinced
she's like i'm going live
we had said this off camera but you were
saying that you're like i'm not even
good at gaming no and i don't believe
you because i see you you're pretty good
you're pretty good but like compared to
like people who stream yeah they're all
so good
yeah someone like me who isn't good
could just do it anyway yeah oh yeah
okay i wasn't good when i started and
like you can also like i'll go live and
do a just chatting stream is what
they're called but like you don't play a
game at all you just talk to people how
is like the gaming world done like how
are the people in are they supportive is
it like more solo or is it you get like
yeah i mean
it's it's interesting because you can
get like
definitely the support is great and
people like don't mind really on twitch
there's so many people that do
everything like there's people who do
music on there like oh you can do
anything on twitch it's crazy oh yeah oh
i thought it was just gaming no so it
started just as gaming and they were
like let's do all of it why not wow what
i think is so badass about you though is
that like in sort of a male dominated
area there aren't a lot of females that
do it and i think okay
first of all beside the fact that you're
stunning and super nice like it's really
cool that you're completely changing the
narrative of it
do you have what is like your female to
male following like ratio yeah i would
say
it totally depends on like
on twitch i'm not 100 sure i know that
on like instagram it's like
12 percent women which is like
interesting about that yeah
it's like so instagram is probably a lot
different than viewer i think this year
has gone up a ton in women
like especially with
um i don't know if you guys have seen
but like the minecraft stuff is really
taken off and like a lot of girls have
like been brought into gaming from that
and so it's been it's been kind of cool
um seeing the numbers like right go up
because one thing that's different about
you though also because i was doing my
little recall yeah
you're also very into fashion and stuff
like that so you're definitely colliding
two totally different industries
together yeah and did you were you more
originally interested in makeup and
beauty and stuff before because i saw
your vlogs yeah
yeah i've always been like really
passionate about that and i didn't
really see myself as like
being able to do both but it's like
gaming has become so mainstream it's
just right so bizarre like everyone's
like oh they're a gamer they do this and
so
um i think with that
it just grows and grows i think it's
important to branch out so i'm like
totally this is my time to like okay
i'll go to fashion week and like yeah
right you know i can do the gaming i can
do the fashion makeup um and i think
that there's
um not a lot of people out there that
are doing that yet but i think it'll be
really big have people been more into
the fact that you have been more open
about showing who you are rather than
just a gamer or do you think you've
because i feel like more girls are
probably like oh my gosh now i can be
right like a reader and a gamer yeah
yeah yeah i think especially especially
with the girl audience like yeah the
guys will watch the tutorials because
they're like okay
i'd make them i'm like oh i just posted
please go watch it right right right
right but like the girls are like can
you post a tutorial on this like
actually wanting to see more i have to
say
before i even met you this could be like
months ago i
remember i watched one of your tutorials
why i swear on youtube and then when i
met you i was like why did she look so
familiar and then i was doing my recon i
go oh my god i've fully like stalked you
before wait and you're so good at it and
you're so cute on your youtube as well
like aside from gaming like you're
vlogging and you're the stuff with your
boyfriend like it's so
sweet and i gotta be honest yeah just
like super on like you show who you are
you're honestly like the exact same you
are online as you are in person which is
like so refreshing
yeah that's like kind of my goal is like
i just kind of want to be upfront about
everything like on my stream i talk
about all the time like mental health i
talk about you know like what it's like
being a girl in this industry because
it's not easy
it's like and stuff trying to like hide
around all this stuff and be like no
everything's great and perfect i love
that you're vulnerable on there because
that's something you know a lot of
people don't use their platform for that
and i think it's so important when
especially when you have a younger
female or a less female audience to sort
of tell them it's okay to be vulnerable
and open up and get help when you're
streaming and obviously there's like
positive comments but i'm sure there's
also a lot of negative comments
does that affect you like i know we had
a lot of viewers um coming and asking
what do we do about like online bullying
or people are being mean like how do you
sort of deal with it yeah i think
well also with like the being live
part of it it's like
when you said you're watching i was like
i was having one of those days yesterday
where i was like oh yeah i was like
sometimes i just
which is not the way to handle it at all
but i will literally like go off i'm
like so upset so upset on stream like
i'll cry on stream i'll have like a full
breakdown gosh five minutes later i'll
be like okay back to the game work but i
think that's fair i think it's important
to feel your feelings yeah because
sometimes it's hard when you're
suppressing or pressing when you're like
you guys this is actually
like hurting me right and helping me let
me show you how it's affecting exactly
and i think it helps because like
definitely once like i
call them out for it like people will
like oh i'm sorry i didn't realize i was
already like that you know okay so you
can confront them yeah oh yeah i'm like
like
yo this person i'll call out their name
i'll be like it's not cool of you to
like
type that in chat or comment on my way
or talk about how i look or anything
like that yeah so
i think it helps to just be straight up
with them and be like and it probably
helps you too oh yeah i'm like i just
gotta vent it out no totally and i think
that also shows like when you do call
someone out all the supporters come in
and they probably go like yeah like get
them off like let's yeah it becomes more
of like a group and you guys are all
bonding together 100 do you have like a
lot of people that reoccur all the time
that you just like are friends with now
yeah yeah so like
they call them like communities on
twitch like who's your like who's in
your community yeah cool so like i will
have people that i know i will see every
single day they'll come back i could
literally name all of them off the top
of my head like oh my gosh they're there
every day typing in chat so it's like i
know where they work i know what you
know i know thing about them but it's
cool because my boyfriend streams as
well and we share a lot of the same
viewers so like when i'm in his stream
like i'll see the same people and then
they'll come over to ours so it's like
oops there you go i'm like sorry i
messed up you should have seen us in the
beginning smacking everything around
yeah so it's cool like you can kind of
see them throughout both of the
communities but yeah you definitely see
people like every single day right and
it's it's nice okay i have to ask about
the boyfriend and the relationship
love talking about dating on this show
so your boyfriend yes he's also a twitch
streamer basically the male version of
you yes how did you guys meet i want to
know everything yeah this is the
craziest story okay
you guys do you guys know who karenikov
is yeah yes okay so karina
i used to watch her youtube back in the
day and this is like when i'm in college
and she came out with
merch it was like pouty girl merch or
whatever and there was a beanie i saw
online i was like this is cute and it
was on sale so i bought it yeah right um
and at the time i was streaming i had
like
30 viewers like just like was a small
streamer yeah and i bought the merch and
then i posted a picture on twitter just
wearing it how cute um and she saw it
and she was like oh hey i see that you
stream on twitch so do i like we should
play games sometime and i was like
that's so nice what the heck i was
freaking out so i'm like oh my god like
yeah this is crazy so
i hadn't heard from her in a little bit
and then she comes into my stream one
day and was like gave me five dollars
and was like let's play let's play right
now and i was like hell yeah i'm
dropping everything like let's go let's
do it
i'm not going to class today right no so
i joined into it was on fortnight so i
joined into her lobby and it's her
um tifu who at the time had like when he
was like 90 000 viewers or something
crazy and then symphony who is now my
boyfriend
by symphony symphony's his like gamer
tag
what a name wow
not his name no his name is mason but
yeah okay so symphonies was like
gamertag but um and they were setting us
up on a blind date oh wait for like a
youtube video so it was like a live
first blind date yes and you guys had no
idea i know
he he they had just invited him and he
was like oh guys no like you know oh
yeah so it's like it's
had no idea it was if you guys watch
this video it is the most uncomfortable
video why because he just didn't know
how to talk to a girl he's no game no
he's a gamer he's like telling me like
about how he like doesn't have his
license and like how he doesn't know how
to draw like just so at what point in
the video
here keep going talk dirty no at one
point in the video did you realize oh my
god i'm totally being set up right now
like no as soon as i was in there
they're like oh this is mason he's this
tall like just like i was like what is
going on did you know who he was before
this i had seen him like once just like
on some like podcast but like it was
like i never thought anything of it no i
thought at the time actually he was like
a total player because he was talking to
this girl oh
[Applause]
but like he literally was like just he
never he had no idea what he was doing
for like months like i i i think that's
so sweet though honestly it was sweet it
was we're on this whole wave right now
where we don't go for the loud funny no
confident cocky which is we like the shy
we like the quiet reserves
normally yeah i i like my ex-boyfriend's
like very loud very yeah no it doesn't
end up working out folks it doesn't work
no listen guys it doesn't work it
doesn't work be the confident
after you're on this stream and you're
like oh my god this guy has zero game
i don't feel any connection here how did
it lead to now dating him like what how
he was like
like live streaming together yeah so we
like people wanted to see us like stream
like so i went from like 30 viewers to
like 10th out like it was oh wow like so
obviously that's amazing we literally
were like telling each other we're like
we should just keep this going for like
the content like
literally that's what the conversation
we had so we kept playing and it was
great and like yeah after a while it was
like just like as a not as a joke but
like just for
the stream um and then i was like wait i
kind of actually like like this guy like
he's like really nice and like i needed
a nice guy a nice nice guy did he live
in the same area as he did no he lived
in texas and i was in oregon at the time
yeah so long distance long distance but
okay so this is what threw me off was he
he would like send me flowers like what
but then he told me he friend zoned me
huh what how did he just say we're
friends i was like so like what where is
this going like what should we you know
this was mine he knew exactly what he
was doing but what does that mean he's
going back and he can't send me flowers
and then friendzoned me that's what i
said she couldn't get him out of his
brain her brain so he probably no but
it's like you're asking me to like you
yeah and then when i do you're like well
i can't yeah what does that mean he's
like well chad said that i should like
send you flowers and stuff i'm like no
but don't do it unless you like
january okay you said the chat oh that's
it oh my god yes it's a type team that's
amazing yeah they would ask you advice
yeah he would ask them what do i do yeah
oh yeah
honestly is this a good outfit yeah but
he i think
what it came down to is like he was he'd
never had a girlfriend never even like
talk to a girlfriend he was like
terrified is what and that didn't like
deter you were just like oh i actually
like that yeah no i was like he's like
really sweet and genuine and like stuff
like that so he told me he was like we
should just be friends and i was like i
respect that but like i think that
you're just
wrong i was like i was like i think you
should like give us a try you
i love
that i was like
like confident when it comes to that
stuff like not normally but like i felt
like
since he had never talked to a girl i
was like okay i gotta take charge here
because otherwise this is never going
anywhere i think that is amazing i mean
look what happened now if you didn't do
it right i mean maybe you guys would
still be like flowers but not just
right now
sometimes people need that like little
extra push and we're also a big believer
in that we don't think it's
real i think we sort of grew up with
this whole false narrative of like the
first time you meet the first time you
kiss you're gonna get this electricity
it's gonna be sparks like oh no we don't
find that to be the case i think the
more you hang out with someone i think
especially on a friendship level that's
when you can really develop like 100
real feelings and that's exactly what
happened here yeah yeah but i love that
you were like no no we're actually going
to go out i'm like you're sending me
flowers like we're going
like
you said he'd never like date anyone did
you kiss anybody was it like i was your
first kiss yes he talks about this on
his stream all the time it was literally
our first kiss was
so awful like that's what he said oh no
i mean he had no idea what to do it's
like oh he just think about my favorite
oh my first kiss right i think back to
my first kiss and i was like oh my god
what was i doing doing yeah yeah but he
it was like it was like kissing a brick
wall like there was nothing
he stopped me in the middle of it and he
goes
he like he goes i i don't know what i'm
doing i was like oh my god i know but
like that's okay i like that he was up
front about that too yeah there's
something so endearing about it oh yeah
do you think maybe he was so just sort
of like up front and honest like instead
of trying to be a cool guy and and play
it off because
maybe he just like really liked you and
wanted to make you happier like maybe
there was something about him not having
any game that
made you like him more yeah
yeah i think it was just like
he just comes across very genuine like
he's just up front and like very honest
and he's just
so sweet we always say this we always
say like it's there's such a nice thing
with innocence when you go out the guy
that like really hasn't had that crazy
of a pass that hasn't had like crazy
axes and you're just like oh wait this
is really easy like i don't have to
worry about anybody i don't have to be
like thinking about someone else because
i used to be crazy so i used to be crazy
in my last relationships no you weren't
crazy
men made you crazy they made me crazy
but they didn't get bored i was always
right like they were cheating or
whatever
have you ever been cheated oh my god i
swear like almost every relationship yes
like who would cheat on you what was
like how did you catch someone cheating
oh god one time i i i was at my parents
house i drove back into like the town
that we were in and i her car was there
and like was at the house at the time i
did that i did this one time i i regret
it i shouldn't you shouldn't do it but i
went through the phone oh i would do it
i'm like
i thought so if they give you a reason
to believe but i was right you know
yeah
i wouldn't just do it to do it you
wouldn't just like go through it it's
like i've never gone through mason's
phone because and it's been over two
years like because i know that you know
yeah you guys are not good at cutting
sinks like you know yeah when something
yeah was this all in oregon i was in
oregon for
okay i moved to l.a gosh
february 2020. oh so really like when
did i yeah it was it was like a month
before covet hit oh my gosh right before
so i moved into our house
it's a content house yeah it's called a
hundred thousand hundred thieves yeah so
what is it like how did you get invited
to it like yeah i wasn't living with a
bunch of people yeah it has a bunch of
guys too yeah they're boys yeah so 100
thieves is like my gaming organization
and
um there's like esports teams where they
like okay
our professional fortnight or valorent
team um and then outside of that there's
content creators so yeah that's what i
am we do crazy videos like we just went
to like adult summer camp for a couple
days
and how was that it was okay what was
105 degrees ah no thank you yeah it was
hot as hell but
we were just like
having drinks and like we were in the
lake and there was archery and there was
ziplining it was really cool and we were
in like cabins so it was like and the
whole time you guys were just creating
content together videos see honestly if
i was gonna be because there's so many
content houses today i was gonna be in
any of them i think it would be
something like this yeah yeah because i
was just reading up on esports
that is so much bigger than i ever
could imagine huge bigger than what like
any sort of football organization or or
fighting organization like
why do you think like the gaming world
in a way it's so underrated and not
spoken about yet it's the biggest one
yeah i don't even know especially since
fortnight like fortnite was kind of like
i feel like where it just went super
mainstream yeah but i feel like so many
of us grew up playing video games with
things like that and like i know people
would give me crap like growing up
you know if you're a gamer like it
wasn't like the cool thing but now it's
like people are like
like you're a gamer it's so bad
in the beginning anything that you know
that's actually the right pop it's never
going to be like the easiest one so
people are always going to give you [ __ ]
i think anything online everybody's like
oh that's so cringe yeah okay now you're
living in a content house are you living
with your boyfriend yeah so so he was he
was helping me move in
and wait was he there before
no so like he helped me move in to the
house but then cope would happen so he
was stuck quarantine like with us oh my
god then it turned into like
a year
and so now he's like staying with us but
i'm with perfect yeah there's uh matt
and jack are my roommates that are in
the organizations and then their two
girlfriends and then my boyfriend so
there's there's six of us total oh my
three couples i love it it's super fun
wait so there's three couples in the
house yeah do you guys go on a lot of
triple dates i was gonna say yeah not
really actually we don't like the whole
thing i guess it's like you see them all
we see them all the time
well you know you see them downstairs or
like on a friday we hang out downstairs
and have drinks or things like that but
like
i don't know because everyone pretty
much is like in their rooms gaming the
whole time there's a lot of gaming going
on and it's great our it's a loud house
like really cause like my roommates they
yell when they're like gaming so you're
like really into it my boyfriend yells
when he because he's a streamer so
there's four of us that stream in the
house oh my gosh loud but like yeah
that's really funny you guys play each
other while you're all like have you
ever done that before um we we've done
it before but like my boyfriend will
play with the guys like a lot so i'll
like know when they're all playing
together i can hear them or like they'll
run into each other's rooms yeah it's
yeah i mean okay so i have to ask what
did your life look like before streaming
and was there anything that you sort of
that sort of happened to you while maybe
you were starting or getting into it
that you're like you know what this
isn't for me like was there something
that completely put you off as well yeah
so before i mean i i just went to school
i went to college i graduated college um
i i streamed the last year my senior
year of college but other than that i
was just like
in college you know hang out party gay
good grades probably
yeah yeah think that it would blow up to
what it is now oh no absolutely not yeah
i just literally did it until i'm like
until i have to get my big girl job and
then all you know yeah then i'll
hang up streaming and be done with it
but
um when i started it was really good um
and then once i met mason like when i
just wasn't prepared for the amount of
people that would just come up or like
would be like so in your business like
it's the weirdest thing when like you go
from 30 viewers to like 10 000 people
thinking they know your relationship in
your life and things like that um and
actually
last year was like the worst of it where
i was like i i almost quit like just
completely disappeared off the internet
what happened i
well
i had a stalker and it turned into five
stalkers so there was a group of
individuals that like would get together
and like
compare notes is like the weirdest one
but like
the fbi was involved it was an entire
thing because they like had addresses
were threatening my parents no like wait
wait so they would watch your lives kind
of compare notes about where you are
like where your parents are like
wherever you are or like like your life
updates and was this like did they ever
show up yeah no so it was it was like
all online but the fbi was involved just
because it was so like
the threats were so aggressive like it
was like the craziest
that was terrible what was their end
goal they wanted me to break up with
mason and then like quit streaming
that's so great i think they're like i
think they're like in love with mason
they're like obsessed with him so they
think that he deserves better and like
just weirdos on the other hand what does
mason respond to it does he oh he just
like
blinds up he's like well you guys are
crazy like get away from me you can't
you can't communicate yeah so how was
that on your i mean even for your mental
state like because i like i've i've said
this on our podcast before i had a
really bad stock that actually showed up
on campus to my college and like went to
my room went to my classes and like they
got him arrested and he flew in from
italy and i know for weeks i was like
about to drop out i wanted to leave and
i was literally about to like become a
hermit but i didn't i'm glad i didn't
but like how was that for you because i
feel like you probably went through some
sort of oh yeah same evaluation of
yourself i was just saying i i decided
i'm like you know what i'm taking
i'm taking a month off just to you know
take care of my mental i mean i was i
wasn't getting out of bed i wasn't
eating i wasn't sleeping like i if i
slept it was like for an hour and then
i'd wake up in a panic because i think
my parents are dead like just it was
messing with me mentally how long of a
period did that last for well that was
like the height of it
total because unfortunately it's still
going on today they didn't get all of
them because it's just there's so many
um
so it's been like over two or i would
say two years yeah
but it's it's everyday that we said like
18 hours a day from like what they saw
like just crazy what they don't take any
days off it's every single day for like
18 hours a day whoa i've blocked
probably like
overall from like twitch twitter
instagram tick tock all of it like over
like 10 000 accounts like well
i cannot believe this yeah don't you do
that as well though like we can not to
this level even in the slightest
i mean how do you like that would just
freak me the [ __ ] out to the point where
i would just quit because
if they're threatening my family yeah
that's my boyfriend like
that's terrifying yeah i know and it's
like to have to it's so like almost
embarrassing to like have to be like go
to my family and be like hey so like
this is what's happening they're saying
but no it it does it feels like
it's your fault you're like and it's not
your fault it's like what i said to them
i was like i feel like this is all my
fault i just didn't stop there like
absolutely not like i'm yeah so your
parents were like keep going like yeah
oh yeah screw them yeah they're super
supportive and stuff and they were like
these guys you know don't worry about us
you know worry about you and yeah just
do your own well i think that's also a
really important lesson within that that
even if sort of people try to harass you
to do something that you don't want to
do is just to ignore them and keep going
and i think that's also really cool i
love that because i've been watching
your like igtvs and stuff like that and
you really do speak directly to people
when you're like try not to let people
and things affect you and like always
try to seek help and and so i really
love that you spread that message yeah i
think it's so important today yeah
absolutely no it's also good to remind
people that are online like you need to
be very aware of who watches you who
follows you because like once you are a
public persona or even if you're one
that has like a thousand followers right
there's always going to be eyes on you
yeah 100 and so you just have to be like
wary of your surroundings in some way
are you like more hyper focused on that
since oh my god i swear every time i'm
like in public i'm like my eyes are like
i'm like always watching yeah it's it's
totally changed the way that i like even
look at people like i don't want to do
you know like
we have all these conventions and things
like for twitch and gaming and all this
stuff it's like it makes me not want to
go to those because you just never know
and so
it's yeah it's definitely changed the
way i look at things but yeah that's
what i tell everyone i'm like if you are
gonna go stream we're gonna you know
pursue being on
tick-tock or you know whatever you're
gonna do make sure that you have
everything covered that your information
is not out there before you do it
because that's that was my problem it's
like
too late you know is this yeah like when
you joined something and you were like
going from zero to 100 right you weren't
like oh let me like make sure my photos
aren't tagged with locations and my
house isn't this and then all of a
sudden yeah it's just like it kind of
yeah you don't expect it because i'm
like it doesn't matter if i have you
know
a color in the background that matches
that yeah just the weirdest things you
have to look into seriously do you think
that if you weren't public with your
relationship that you'd be getting the
same harassment oh 100
like that's like one of my biggest
regrets well it's hard because that's
what made my career like happen was my
relationship with mason is like what
people wanted to watch and things like
that but at the same time that's what
brought on so much of the hate and it's
like
even like now
i mean the stalkers they think that i'm
cheating on him which is why they like
yeah that's what that's why they that
would yeah crazy people not only it's
like
you have to deal with strangers getting
involved in a relationship has it ever
caused like a fight between you always
because i mean it's just like it's just
weird i mean they'll like message him
when he's streaming he streams he starts
streaming at 3am every morning so what
wait
yeah yeah yeah
three yeah he likes to be on before
everyone else gets on he's like boy
he's like early bird gets the worm i
hate it so three a.m and then he'll get
done around like 12 or one and three a.m
it'll be like it'll be like 6 a.m and
they'll be typing in his chat like go
upstairs she has a guy up there she's
cheating on you i'm like i am asleep
[Applause]
yeah he'll go to bed at like probably
like nine every night so that's the time
i'm in bed but i'm not up at three no no
i mean i've and now i'm in i'm i go to
bed like super early now because
have you ever done this live like like
like very early live streams i haven't
gone live at that time i've been live
like until that time where i'm like oh
shoot like it's 3am yeah or i've done
like a lot of people do 24-hour streams
when you just stream nonsense 24 hours
yeah okay
my brain would it's falling off i
literally feel like a zombie at the end
of it like that sounds like you've done
it 24 hours
yeah what yeah you just like you don't
sleep you just do you walk around no you
just sit for 24 hours yeah you just play
games did your eyeballs hurt oh yeah
yeah but people like now it's like not
even 24 hours like they're called
subathons where every time you get a
subscriber you add um time to a timer oh
geez and it erases timer people have
been live like they'll do like three
days four days
we had someone broke a record it was
like over a month
he slept on stream and stuff but he like
had his stream non-stop going for over a
month just did not end it he slept on
stream yeah
yeah so that is like a big brother i
don't know if i would want to i know and
like
people will like play videos like while
he's like asleep but it is the weirdest
like people will like watch people do
sleeping streams oh
my god that's what i don't know what's
wrong it is commitment i don't know
what's worse to stream knowing that
people are watching you or being the
watcher they're watching someone sleep
i've been there i'm not related to this
level at all but i've been there where
i'm talking to a guy and we're like
should we facetime fall asleep together
and i'm like sure i guess so do you have
to prop your phone up and he watches me
sleep 10 seconds later i'm like i'm
hanging out this is creepy i do that i
literally would that was always like to
do that
don't watch me have you ever seen those
videos of facetiming and the girl for
like falls asleep and he puts on like a
fake
um end calling
and then she wakes up and she was
pretending to be asleep yeah you got to
be careful with that because they'll get
you they'll get you yeah they'll do that
is there anything else from the gaming
world because i'm so fascinated like
we've not we're not involved in it yeah
there's so many things we have questions
about but what's like the craziest thing
you learned or like being involved and
seen in the gaming world like i mean the
tw month staying awake or on live is
just and the way you grew followers so
quickly like what's something that's so
i would say i mean like the big things
have happened that was a huge deal when
ludwig is his name he's one of my
friends he did the
the i got i want to say it was even more
than a month like it was non-stop uh it
was the biggest deal but like the way
that people like collab with celebrities
now is kind of crazy like right like in
fortnite uh ninja played with drake you
know on stream they played fortnite
together like you just see these guys so
yeah yeah so like they'll play oh my god
my boyfriend will play with like
a lot of like the nfl players or nba
players like
love video games because that's why you
gotta start yeah
okay that's clever yeah but they all
play and so like they'll reach out to
mason be like oh let's get some games in
and he's like
he doesn't watch the sport so he's like
has no idea who these people are and i'm
like i'm like go go play closely
i
captioning
not
oh it's so available it was it was
really cool when they did we should
probably jump on the bandwagon before
the bandwagon yeah you're going to be
brooke is going to teach us brooke is
going to teach her you guys should
totally do it you guys yeah when this
comes out we'll be streaming the three
of us yeah it's going to be amazing
so to girls that like want to join
gaming what would you say the biggest
advice is like to get on if they're like
nervous to join like what would you say
to them definitely you're going to have
to have thick skin like just ignore
you get the dumbest people like
trust me like even in like when i play
valorent and you have to like your
teammates are random people you don't
know and you have to talk to them and
stuff
they'll because you're a girl tell you
to shut up go to the kitchen you know
stupid stuff oh yeah and you just have
to like literally just let it roll off
your back because if you have any good
comebacks when they say stuff like that
i i i on stream sometimes i'll mute my
mic and then like
i'm like so my stream can't hear what
i'm saying oh you're too polite i think
i would say some things i would regret
it's and that's that's the hard thing
about being alive is like you just want
to like go off and i'm like scared like
a sponsor and like click on my stream
when i'm like
freaking out on this guy you should have
like one of those buttons have you seen
those red buttons that say something you
should just have like as an autumn like
a shut up shut up
literally yeah you didn't say it no it
wasn't it so
i want to know what is next for brooke
like you're collaborating i mean you're
combining fashion and gaming you have
this content house you have a thriving
relationship what's something that you
would love to sort of tackle whether
it's on your instagram whether it's your
youtube channel yeah i definitely want
to start
um i'm just so passionate about you know
like i love the fashion makeup world i
think it's so fun i think um for me i
think that's like
would be amazing if i can balance both
of those
perfectly and you know just be able to
you know do my tutorials and then
post a
gaming video afterwards like do great on
both of those like collabing with like a
makeup company i was just gonna say yeah
has there ever been uh like a morphe x
gamer girl palette i'm sorry that would
be so fun so great so insane yeah i
think that that would be like the dream
one day to be honest i see it i already
know it's gonna happen and i'm buying it
okay okay get on twitch and do it oh my
god i love it i love it brooke thank you
so much for coming on today i mean i
don't even know if people you need to
plug because they probably already
follow you but tell everyone where they
can find your twitch your instagram your
youtube brookaybee on twitch youtube and
twitter brookeabbe
on instagram there we go thank you so
much for coming with you guys we'll be
streaming soon yes bye guys bye guys
[Music]
you